Hello Freak bitches.
You wanted to be the head
of police of Chicago,
is that still going on?
No,
I mean they certainly,
uh,
the corruption went in and so we
can tell that story real quick.
What they did is they
did a national search,
so the laws in Chicago said that this,
uh,
appointed police board has to do a
nationwide search and then they give three
names to the mayor.
The mayor investigates those
people and then chooses one.
So I predicted they weren't
going to go with me.
I'm too far ahead still that no one's
really ready to take that bite yet,
but it's still something we could have
talked about and they would have had the
opportunity.
I figured they would pick that,
uh,
that I figured they'd pick a black guy
who was educated and not from Chicago.
Uh,
that was my prediction and that's
who the police board did choose.
They chose a guy from Atlanta
who fit that bill to the t.
He was going to be
the black guy that represents the police
department but still totes their line.
Um,
I'm thinking of a word that everybody
knows and I'm not saying it so you can all
pick up on what I'm suggesting.
You're saying uncle Tom.
Yeah.
And,
and let people have an uncle
Tom and he's a nice guy.
So if you have an uncle
and his name is Tom,
don't worry about it.
So that's what they're going to look for.
Something that will have
visually a seems satisfying.
I see.
Good instructionally be exactly the same.
So they chose that guy and
the mayor are still said,
yeah,
I don't know what that guy I want you
was this guy that didn't even apply.
And that skews the commissioner.
So who is this guy that didn't
imply he was couple ranks down.
I'm already in the agency.
He is a,
he said that he has never seen misconduct
or corruption in the Chicago Police
Department and his entire
20 something year career,
he is intimately tied into a cheating
scandal and the promotional tests.
Another thing which
you could solve easily.
So his friends like wife or
something got number one,
the lieutenant's test,
which is extremely a qualifying.
So say.
And as soon as the information comes down
that he actually was the one that was
developing the tests,
had the answers,
and then she gets this super
high score out of nowhere.
And you know,
as when everybody says,
oh,
come on,
we've seen this before,
we know what it is,
so you can solve it,
you could retest them.
Right.
And see who does it.
But at first of course not.
So they're not going to do that.
Did they have any interest
in exposing things?
So if I'm going to come in
there and I'm going to say,
all right,
that's it.
We're going to be transparent,
I don't think there.
Okay.
So now when you say that you
were a little too far ahead,
what do you mean by that?
Well,
it seems the people of a city or of any
area have to be pushed hard enough to,
to have that change.
Like they have to have that breaking
point where they say that's it.
We're going to do something different.
Because what I really push is
for civilian controlled policing.
I want you guys to tell me what,
what should be done,
which is a huge drop in power,
so that's,
that would require a mayor that's willing
to give in to the people that have
pushed hard enough to say,
look,
I'm going to relinquish control of my
essential armed wing and I'm going to give
it to the people,
and so what's been done before?
Not that I'm aware of,
not in America.
It certainly hasn't.
So who's going to be the
city that takes that leap?
It has to come.
It has to.
We all know it.
One of the things that I've been
ranting about a lot lately is choice.
You know,
and people this.
We live in a society that loves
to take choice from us and say,
all right,
everything is a disease.
Everything is privilege.
Everything is this thing.
You know,
you really didn't have a choice because
there were these preconceived conditions
and and it really is robbing
us of choice because with,
if we accept our inherent superpower,
which is choice,
then we have responsibility for who we
are and if we have responsibility for who
we are,
all of us have such a harsh self
judge that every failing we have,
if we say,
well,
it was up to us,
the judge just beats us to death about it.
So we'd rather shrug our responsibility
and go with our hands up to the judge.
Judge,
it wasn't my fault,
it wasn't my fault because we have such
a harsh self judge in our own head that,
that we intend to do that.
So we,
we give up our inherent superpower,
which is choice because we don't
want to take the responsibility,
but at any point we can take that back
and you have to deal with the judge and
you deal with the judge by making
a pact to always forgive yourself.
Forgive yourself for any of the fucked
up things that have happened and just
accept that we're all imperfect.
This idea of perfection is nonsense.
We're all going to fuck up.
We're all gonna,
make mistakes,
and so the judge is,
this is nonsense.
You know,
it's like we're all gonna
have come to the place.
We are,
you know,
through any variety of channels and
we're going to be an imperfect path no
matter what.
So continued to pound that own message
of self love and forgiveness and then re
harness that element of choice so that
we can then decide what we want to be,
who we want to be,
what we want to go and put our intent.
Fourth and yeah,
and maybe not everything is possible,
but what better thing to do than than to
fail in the cause of your greatest wish
and your greatest intention
in your greatest desire.
I mean,
that's the ultimate warriors death.
That's what they would talk about with
Vala to find an enemy worthy enough to
kill me in battle.
That was the ultimate idea and we can
all choose those battles and choose that
thing that we're fighting for and fuck,
if we fail,
so what?
But at least if we're
going out on that way,
you know,
we'll go out with a smile
100 percent of the time.
But it starts with really
harnessing that choice.
I've got a bunch of shit for
coming against the naked shows.
They do comedy shows,
what?
Naked shows.
They do these naked comedy
shows in New York sometimes.
So yeah,
the whole audience is naked.
No,
just the comics.
Oh,
what the fuck?
I was doing this.
We're doing this thing,
this weekend's gang fest for two
days for Legion skanks and uh,
at the creek and the
cave in Long Island city.
And we're having a,
a naked roast battle.
I see the novelty in it.
I argued with a girl comic
who's talking about like,
this is about getting
over things and you know,
there's this artistic back to it.
I go,
whatever you say,
I'm just telling you.
Every guy goes there to see pussy.
And she's at her argument was just like,
no,
like people want to see like,
you know,
the social experiment
of it and see what I go.
I'm going to look at policy and I'm
telling you that I am Joe average in my
thoughts,
like I am common guy,
but she'll run into a guy
who argue against that,
but I don't even go
there for personalities.
I like to hear these people talk.
So she came on our
podcast with a dude who.
Yeah,
it was the whole thing goes,
Nah man.
It's about like,
you know,
getting over fears
copies.
I'm like,
dude,
you are just so excited to
be with a girl that like,
like backstage with a girl and everyone
is like sitting there with your Dick and
pussies out.
Yup.
We used,
me and Kurt used to do a Gig in Philly.
It was and where you could do comedy once
in a while at a burlesque place called
the five spot or less like a date.
They did dancing with their clothes on,
you know,
they get down to the pastries
and everything and the,
and the goofy outfits.
But me and Kurt would
do this once a month.
We'd be like,
do comedy on that show.
In between.
The first time we did it,
we were bags and we were
blown away because it's,
you never do it.
Well,
they go,
don't be weird.
Backstage dogs,
you know,
what's the theater technically so the
girls are running around naked know
they're changing so they're just naked
a lot and sometimes they would just sit
around naked smoking
cigarettes back there,
butt naked,
sitting down in chairs.
Pussy all mashed up and me
and me and I shouldn't even care throw
curtains under the bus like this.
I'll speak for myself only.
I was just staring at
tits and pussy is nonstop.
I just I'll speak for.
I was when he was doing,
I was staring at him and then the next
week and the next time he came in,
the next month it was a,
there was like they put like partitions
up for the girl and I'm like,
yeah,
but I'm not going to pretend that I
wasn't back there to look above what you
want me to force myself
to look into your eyes.
If you're that comfortable being naked,
then be comfortable
with me staring at you.
Buzzy.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
That's me,
a tee shirt.
It should.